the day after news broke that Alec will
face charges for involuntary
manslaughter for his role in the rest
movie shooting the ball Blitz step out
new photo Alec hiding his face trying to
escape photogs as he heads into an
office building this morning wifey Laria
accompanied by a bodyguard shielded her
eyes with Shades her sweatshirt breathes
empathy please
leave my family in peace and let this
all play out because I'm not going to
say anything and Alec is not going to
say anything a source tells E.T both are
devastated about his charges there's no
way anyone could have been prepared for
something like this
while Alec could face up to five years
in prison Stephen Baldwin is coming to
his brother's defense he reposted the
statement from Alex Budd Mickey Rourke
quote no way in hell actor Alec Baldwin
should be charged most actors don't know
anything about guns guns are supposed to
be handled only by the weapon armorer
there might be people on Baldwin's Camp
who say that you were overcharging this
well we disagree and we're going to be
taking that in front of a judge the
prosecution is going to argue well no
Alpha was actually more than just an
actor on that set he took on many roles
that made him not just responsible for
that moment in time but for also the
safety that existed as a whole on the
Saturday just last October the studio
announced plans to resume filming maybe
in California of course pending charges
against Alec who is one of the producers
could put that in Jeopardy the big
question now could his own words be used
against him in court do you feel guilt
no no things for me are going to get
cleared up I have I'm a thousand percent
confident about that you have to decide
you want to leave it in the hands of a
jury or do you want to have some control
and take a plea in order to avoid some
more serious sentencing